Hello everybody!
Hello, hello!
Today is a new exciting day of trying to make technology work.
I see a lot of people are like, the fuck is Seaman?
So, I don't know why.
Okay, so, this game has lived rent-free in my head for the longest time.
And I've always wanted to try this game out.
And I've only watched one playthrough of this game.
And it was years ago.
I think it was like...
It was 10 plus years ago when PewDiePie did a Let's Play of Seaman.
And then, that game has lived rent-free in my head for so fucking long, that like...
I was like, wait a minute.
I can... I can play Seaman now.
I've never had a Dreamcast before.
That's not gonna stop me!
So, Seaman.
You can only play Seaman on the Dreamcast with a very special...
With a very special microphone that is fit...
Like a microphone controller or something.
And I've never owned a Dreamcast before.
Anyway, today we're gonna play...
Today, we're gonna play Seaman!
Seaman!
And it's basically...
It's basically like a Tamagotchi.
But instead of raising a really cute pet, you're raising a fish of a human man's face.
Who's voiced by Leonard Nimoy.
Or back then, because this game was actually released in 2000.
And it was...
If you guys didn't know, he's based Leonard Nimoy for the young ones out there, the Gen Zers out there.
And I guess like... Who is the newest Gen Alpha?
Is that the newest one that's growing up right now?
This is voiced by Mr. Spock from Star Trek.
Not the... Oh, what's his name?
The newest Spock.
I forgot his name.
The other guy.
I know Chris Pine is the captain.
By the way, I've never actually watched Star Trek before.
Okay, you can... You guys... Okay.
I will not judge you if you... Oh, Zach.
Yeah, Zach Quinto.
Yeah, Zachary Quinto.
Yes, Zachary Quinto, who's the newest Spock actor.
The heroes guy.
Anyway, the only things... The only references I know regarding Star Trek...
Is the ones... Please... Okay.
I allow you guys to judge me when I tell you guys this.
If this is like, the last straw...
This might be the last straw for a lot of you guys.
Especially the older Dragoons.
But the only things I know from Star Trek...
Are the references made...
The references...
By the way, I did not watch that show.
I just... I try to watch the first... Okay.
The references made by Big Bang Theory.
Because I try to watch the first... I try to watch the first season.
Because back then... Back then, when Big Bang Theory was still running...
It was considered the most popular TV show.
That's in circulation.
That was running.
So I was like... Oh, hey.
Let me check it out.
Let me send this in.
Sorry.
I was like... I mean, it won a lot of... It won a lot of...
It won a lot of... What is it?
Like, lots of... Oh my god.
What was the TV awards?
I forgot what it's called.
It was not TV awards.
I'm trying to remember what it was called.
The Emmys.
It won a lot of Emmys.
And like, you know, the People's Choice Awards and shit like that.
So I was just like... Let me check it out.
I couldn't get past the first season, as we all know.
It's a show.
But, I learned a lot about Star Trek, though.
At least I learned a lot.
Guys, I learned a lot about Star Trek, though.
I promise.
Our relationship is over, Toki.
Simple-minded.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Wait, I said... Guys, I said like...
I didn't actually watched, watched it.
Also, thank you for the...
Thank you, thank you.
Hello.
Also, the other times I know about...
I think the other... What was the other thing that made me know more about Star Trek?
I'm trying to remember.
Like, because they used to do like... A lot of shows would...
Oh, Patrick Stewart.
Sir Patrick Stewart.
Also, because of...
Also, because of American Dad.
Because Sir Patrick Stewart voice acts in American Dad.
So he always... They always reference Picard.
They always make references to him.
Since Patrick Stewart is like a character in that show.
So I knew a lot about like... A lot about like Picard as well because of it.
Guys, guys, look.
American Dad is actually a pretty good show, okay?
It's actually a pretty decent show.
Okay, guys.
El, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That's it.
I'm un-subbing and cancelling myself.
I can't believe my oshi did this to me.
Thank you for the super chat, El.
Thank you, thank you.
Pamper, thank you for the super chat.
Star Trek, watch along.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Mercy, thank you for the super chat.
Doki, you're getting us to play by play on Archie.
Why would we expect you to have standards?
Look, I admit I have really, really trashy taste when it comes to TV shows, okay?
You know what I used to watch growing up?
I said this before.
I know I have trashy taste in TV shows.
Because I used to watch Toddlers in Tiara.
Which is like, really trashy.
For those who don't know what Toddlers in Tiara is.
It's like, I talked about this before.
But it's when, it's when like, it's like kids beauty pageants.
And they like, force feed their children a lot of fucking sugar.
Called like, pixie sticks.
And they're like, perform for us.
Make mommy proud.
Because mommy didn't fucking, wasn't able to do this when she was growing up.
So I'm gonna live vicariously through you.
So I used to watch Toddlers in Tiara a lot when I was growing up.
Because I used to actually really enjoy it.
When I was growing up, when I was growing up guys, I don't do that anymore.
Oh yeah, and the go-go juice.
I don't do that anymore, guys.
I like to think that I've matured a lot more.
Now, I just watch children animation.
Now, and comedy sitcoms.
But like, not skip, sorry, not sitcoms.
And comedy shows, like Abbott Elementary.
And, what else do I watch actually?
I don't know, usually I just watch like, animation.
And, oh, I like Crapopolis.
Crapopolis is really good.
Speaking of children animation, did you hear that they're planning on trying to cancel Sesame Street?
I was like, what the fuck?
We're actually, that's fucking crazy.
Yeah, they're trying to get Sesame Street off the air.
And I was like, leave Elmo alone!
What has Elmo done to you?
That's crazy.
No, they're actually trying to take Sesame Street off the air.
I was like, what the fuck?
That's fucking insane.
Elmo just wants to hug.
What did Elmo do to you?
Holy fuck.
Anyway, Quantum, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hi, Doki, today is my birthday.
Can you get a happy birthday wish from my cameo?
Of course I can!
Happy birthday, Quantum.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Happy birthday to you, happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Quantum.
Happy birthday to you.
Wait, he's not the voice of the fish man?
I thought he was.
It sounds just like him.
I thought he was the voice of the fish man.
Okay, let me see.
Oh wait, why is it not full screen anymore?
Oh my god, what did I do?
Give me a sec, guys.
I fucked up the game because I tabbed out.
I mean, I fucked up the stream thing because I tabbed.
I accidentally closed my Dreamcast.
That's...
That's okay, I figured it out.
I figured it out.
Okay, let's see.
Is this correct?
Okay, okay.
Alright, I'm booting up my Dreamcast right now, guys.
I'm booting it up.
Guys, I'm doing it.
I'm running my...
I'm running...
Well, alright, let me see if my screen capture works.
Let me see if my screen capture works for Seaman.
Is it this?
Which one is... oh, it's this.
There we go.
Alright, do we want to create?
Yes.
Yeah, I see.
No, guys, don't see that.
Okay.
Okay, wait.
Why is my...
Why is it not working?
Hello?
It's not working.
Okay, there we go.
Okay, give me a sec.
My Dream...
My Dreamcast controller...
Okay, give me a sec, guys.
I got...
Okay, give me a sec.
I'm trying to figure... Okay, there we go.
Okay.
Hello?
Oh.
Oh, I accidentally clicked no.
Oh, okay.
I got it to work.
Okay.
Wait, what?
Okay, there we go.
Play.
Oh, my God.
Wait, did I...
Oh, it's because I clicked no.
Oh, okay.
Okay, I get it.
Play.
I'm doing it.
I...
I've never seen... Guys, I've actually... I've never seen...
What the...
What a Dreamcast looks like.
Until today.
The menu looks like...
Wait.
Yes.
Why won't it let me create new data?
Let me...
What?
What the fuck?
Why won't it?
Why won't it let me create?
I'm using the D-pad.
It won't let me go to the left.
Okay, we can figure this out.
It's okay, guys.
We can figure this out.
I pressed A.
Yay!
Okay, wait.
Okay.
Oh!
I have to use the left trigger!
Okay, I'm figuring it out, guys.
It's the left trigger button.
Ryzen, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Okay,
Mr. Seaman.
Do I have a start button?
What's my start button?
Guys, give me a sec.
Like, I don't think I have a start button.
Give me a sec.
Okay, start is...
Okay, there you go.
Guys, sorry, I...
I had to...
plug in my controller on and off.
And I got... Guys, it's okay, guys.
I had to plug in my controller on and off.
That's why I had to hide my screen, guys.
Yeah?
So yeah, it's like a Tamagotchi.
Welcome!
Welcome to the tomato farm!
Welcome, welcome!
Welcome!
Leonard Nimoy!
There he is!
Oh, game was a little...
You guys don't see that, right?
You guys don't...
You guys don't see it, okay.
While adjusting, keep in mind that blue is the color of the sea.
And thus, an appropriate color for the care of seaman.
Then, take the egg from the storage matrix and place it in the tank.
The water's temperature is key...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The Nautilus will play a very important role in seaman's development.
Affiliate, thank you for the five gift issues!
Thank you, thank you!
I'll be here to offer advice and guidance.
Thank you, Mr. Nimoy!
You may press the start button to skip at any time.
Very well.
Let us proceed to the tank.
Mr. Sand, did you also remember the plug-in that definitely...
Yeah!
My very real...
Okay, here we go.
My very real Dreamcast microphone that's attached to my Dreamcast controller right now that I'm holding.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Of course, how else would I get this game to work, guys?
Hello?
Is my seaman here?
Hello, Mr. Seaman?
Where are you?
Hello?
Would you like to save and end the session?
Wait, where is he?
Hello?
Wait, do I turn on the lights?
Where are my lights?
Where is it?
How do I turn on light?
Hello?
Instructions?
Where is my light?
Oh my God, where is it?
It's so dark.
It's so dark, I can't see anything.
Okay, wait, I'm clicking everything.
Oh, where did you...
Oh my God, read the manual.
Oh my God, where is it?
Oh my God, it's somewhere here.
I'm trying to find it.
Turn the... Oh my God, where is it?
Mr. Nimoy, where is my light?
Wait, that's an egg.
Wait, I want to place...
Maybe I'll find it here.
Maybe if I tap everything.
Okay, wait, maybe if I...
Can I grab this?
I'll grab this.
I want to grab it.
Give me the egg.
Oh my God, please.
I'm tapping.
Where are you?
Am I an egg?
Oh,
I have to...
What?
Oh, I have to hold...
Wait.
Okay.
Did I grab it?
No, I didn't.
Okay, we're going to figure this out, guys.
We're going to...
Oh, I grabbed it.
Wait, how did I do that?
Mr. Nimoy, how did I do that?
Mr. Nimoy, I let go of the egg.
Wait, Mr. Nimoy.
I don't let go.
I couldn't help it.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Where is it?
Where did I drop it?
Where did I drop the egg?
Where is it?
It made...
It made a plop sound.
It plopped some...
Oh, it's gone.
It's gone.
It plopped.
And I don't know where I plopped it.
Where is it?
Mr. Nimoy.
I don't know where it is.
I'm so confused.
Mr. Nimoy.
Oh, my God.
Where did it go?
Where did the egg go?
Okay.
Maybe...
I grab...
Okay.
I'm gonna grab the food pellet, though.
Okay, I'm gonna feed it.
I think it's somewhere in here.
I...
I'm trying to figure out...
I'm trying...
I'm trying to figure out where the light switch is, guys.
That's the hardest part.
But, Mr. Nimoy, how do I turn on the light?
I don't...
I'm...
I don't know where it is.
It's too dark.
You keep making this look harder than Dark Souls.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, Raz.
Guys!
Where's the light?
Where is it?
Where is the light?
Where is...
The tapping is quite loud.
Oh, that's funny, because you can't...
You can't adjust sound on the Dreamcast, guys.
I'll turn it down, though.
Okay.
Wait, it's right there?
It's right there?
Where?
How do you guys see the light switch?
Guys, how...
How do you see it?
Okay, wait.
Okay, what if I end my run?
I end my run, and then he'll tell me where the light switch is.
Maybe he'll tell me.
Don't worry, Mr. Nimoy.
Okay.
I believe in him.
He'll...
He'll tell me, right?
Wait.
Oh, do I have to turn it on and off?
Turn the light off.
Oh, I can't even play the game?
Oh, my God, what?
Oh, wait, no, okay.
I need to press start.
Okay.
I'm back in.
Don't worry.
We're figuring...
The first part is trying to figure out where the light switch is, guys.
And then I'll talk to my child.
Alright.
I don't even know where the egg is.
Where's the egg?
Hello?
Where's my child?
Where is it?
Where's the child I put in here?
Where...
Where is he?
Wait, do I even...
Where did the child go?
Where is he?
Okay, we have figured it out.
Apparently, it's the D-pad.
Guys, I don't have enough.
Guys, I need you to know...
I don't have en...
I don't have enough buttons for this.
I...
Let me figure this out.
Okay.
Okay, I have enough buttons now.
I have enough buttons now.
I figured it out.
Okay.
Wait.
It says light.
How do I...
I have light.
How...
How to turn light?
Where did...
Where's the child?
Where...
Where is it?
Child, where are you?
Oh, there he is!
Oh my god, there's the child!
Okay.
Okay, I figured it out.
Okay, there he is.
Okay, and then I'll heat you up.
Don't worry, child.
Be warm!
I'll warm you up, child!
Don't worry!
Are you warmed up now?
Hello?
Wake up!
Oh shit.
Okay, wait.
Okay.
Don't worry.
I'll warm you up.
But how do I know if it's cooked or not?
Doki, stop!
Oh, hey, look!
There's air!
There's air in the system now.
Guys.
Look, I'm doing it!
I'm a really good fish owner!
Is it blue?
Oh, it's blue!
Look at that!
There's more air now.
I think I'm a really good...
I think I'm a really good caretaker.
Why are you sleeping?
Wake up, Mr. Nimoy!
We're resurrecting you from the grave.
So you can be in a VTuber's Let's Play.
It's okay, they need more air.
We all know fishes need air.
100!
Gotta make it extra blue!
Okay.
And then...
And then we need...
What do we need?
Light, air, heater.
Okay.
No, no!
The egg's not dead, guys!
Believe!
Gotta heat it up!
We gotta cook the seaman!
Mr. Seaman?
Wake up, wake up!
We're gonna make you nice and warm!
Nice and toasty!
Wake up, wake up!
Don't...
It's fine!
It's just a little cooked!
Just, we're gonna...
Make sure the brain...
Develops a little more.
Oh, wait!
It's moving!
The baby's moving!
Oh my God.
Okay.
Okay, now...
Okay, and then...
Hello?
Wake up!
Come on!
Wake up for me!
I see you!
Don't...
Don't be boring!
Wake up and give me content!
Entertain me!
Entertain me right now!
Oh, it's time to advance the clock?
Oh!
Oh, we're gonna cheat!
Okay, let's do that.
Okay, yes.
Yes, okay, we advance the clock.
Okay.
How far do you think we should advance it?
Guys.
Wait.
What happens if I...
Okay, how do I get to the main menu?
On the Dreamcast.
Guys, let me figure this out.
I need to figure out how to get to the main menu.
We're gonna be time traveling real fast, guys.
Okay, let's see.
I'm gonna look at my controller too, real fast.
Oh, you're right.
Okay.
Oh, I forgot.
I just press a button.
On my...
On the console.
And it should...
It should...
Take me back, right?
Take me to the main menu.
Right?
Alright.
That should be it.
Is that it?
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Settings.
Uh, date and time.
Wait, it does do that.
Wait.
Oh my...
What if I like...
Okay, but what if I...
How dead is my egg?
How...
Maybe he's a full grown adult now.
Maybe...
Maybe he's an adult, guys.
You don't know that.
He could be an adult now.
Oh my god, it's his birthday.
Guys.
Oh, shit.
Just days, guys.
So cool.
Oh, he's gonna hatch!
Wait, he's gonna hatch!
Guys.
Please.
Please be patient.
Okay.
Okay, Mr. Nemo.
Wait.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, where...
Wait, where is he?
Where is he?
Wait, where did my...
Where did my...
Oh, no, not...
It's okay.
He's okay, right?
Oh, my egg is still there, guys!
Look!
He's still there!
Look at that!
No, he's still alive!
Look at him!
Look, he's still there!
He's still there.
Look.
See, I did not kill the egg.
It's still...
Happy birthday!
It's your...
It's your one year old little egg!
Happy birthday!
He's about to hatch, guys!
He's about to hatch!
Oh my god!
Happy birthday!
Okay, now we put on the heat.
Okay.
It's okay, he's fine.
Oh my god!
Little guy!
It's your birthday, little guy!
You gotta get out of there soon!
Can't live in that little egg forever!
You gotta pay rent!
Okay, let's give him more...
More heat real fast.
It's okay, it's okay.
He's gonna hatch.
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, dear little guy!
Yay!
Okay, let's see.
It says...
Not above 20.
So I'll put it at 19.9.
Oh, that's awkward.
How do I lower that?
Okay.
It's okay.
He'll be fine.
JB, thank you for the superchat!
Thank you!
Watching Doki talk to Leonard Nimoy and raising a seaman was not on my VTubing bingo card for sure.
Thank you for the superchat, GG!
Thank you, thank you!
It's okay, guys.
Okay, and then...
Then we look at him.
Hello?
Are you gonna hatch now?
Okay, I wanna zoom in.
How do I zoom in?
Oh my god, he's moving!
Oh, there he is!
Oh my god, there he is!
Look, look!
He's so alive!
You're so alive, little guy!
I knew you're alive!
They didn't believe me.
They said I killed you, but I would never.
I would never commit manslaughter or fish slaughter.
Oh my god, look at him!
He's getting bigger!
I don't know how I zoomed in, though.
How did I do that?
Okay.
Oh my god, it's dividing!
It's in seaman!
No, he's dividing!
He's actually dividing!
Oh my god, it's working!
Mitosis!
Oh my god, he's making the mitochondria right now!
Oh shit.
I wanna get closer.
Oh my god, keep dividing!
Oh my god, it's quadruplets!
I'm watching mitosis work in real time!
Come on.
Finish.
Divide faster!
If I tap it, it'll divide faster, right?
Oh my god, look!
He has little tails, too!
Oh my god, there's many seamans in there!
Come on.
So, is it tapping a lot better now?
I'm patient.
I'm waiting.
Come on, little guy.
Grow up.
Come on!
Grow the fuck up!
It says five minutes.
Has it been five minutes yet?
Hello?
Hello, child?
What if I feed him right now?
Okay, let me grab this.
How do I grab this again?
I don't remember.
Guys, how do I-
Did it work?
Oh, there it is!
Look, seaman!
I got you your food!
This tiny-ass food right here!
You gotta wake up to grab it!
It's right here!
Look!
Seaman!
It's right here!
Wake up!
You gotta swim all the way there!
Come on, little buddy!
Come on!
Thank you for the akasupa again!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Thank you for the akasupa!
Thank you- What the fuck?
What?
There's multiple?
What the fuck is that?
Wait, what?
What are they?
Oh my god!
I thought they'd be fishies!
I thought they'd still develop!
What are you?
Tap, tap, tap, tap, tap, tap.
Tap, tap, tap.
Tap, tap, tap, tap, tap, tap, tap.
You want more food?
Hello?
Eh.
Oh, I can't place food anymore.
There's too much food.
But I only placed one food.
What do you mean?
There's so many of them!
Oh my god, it's like a little eye!
Oh my god, look at him!
He's just stuck up there!
Okay, uh...
I'll make sure you have enough.
Okay, what if I- Oh, oh, they're just...
They're just up there.
Oh my god, that's freaky!
How long do they stay as an eye?
No, they're still alive!
See?
Watch.
Look at that!
No, 99 point- Yeah, they're like eyes!
Doki's the best mother a dragoon could ask for!
Koyuki, thank you for the- Oh my god, look at them!
They're just rolling around!
Wait, tap the shell.
What does the shell do?
Oh, shell.
This is how I was born!
Ryusen, thank you for the super chat!
Oh my god, wait!
There's somebody- Something inside this!
Wait, there's a- There's a little thing inside the shell!
Oh look, they're like juggling!
Oh my god, you guys are so ugly!
Oh my god!
They'll become more beautiful, right?
They'll grow out of their ugly face, right?
I don't think I love you.
Wait, this stage lasts for four to five days?!
Okay, do I need to feed them?
Okay.
Do I- Do I need to feed these creatures?
Wow!
Do I need to feed them, guys?
I need to- No?
Okay, I'll see you in four to five days, little bitch.
We're time traveling.
Don't worry.
We're gonna travel a little- We're gonna travel a little bit.
Three to four days.
Okay.
Wait, when does March- Okay.
One...
Two...
Three...
Four...
Five.
Alright.
There we go.
Don't worry.
Mom's coming back now.
They'll be fine, right?
They don't need to eat, right, guys?
This woman hasn't fed her kids in five days.
I'm calling CPS.
It's okay, they'll be fine.
They'll be fine.
They'll be so healthy.
Don't worry.
Mama's coming back with food.
Don't worry, I'm here now.
Oh.
Are they okay?
Oh yeah, they're pretty fucking ugly.
Oh.
Oh shit.
Wait, what happened to the other two?
Oh wait, okay.
No, three.
Oh wait, five died.
Okay, survival of the fittest, guys.
Survival...
That means they're strong.
My children...
The ones that remain are the strong ones.
It's okay.
Survival of the fittest.
Those other five were not gonna live anyway.
In the long run.
It's natural selection.
If they die by the cord...
Fuck, okay.
Shit!
Okay.
It'll be fine.
No, no, no, I'm heating it up, guys.
It's what nature wanted.
It's what...
No, they're not dead!
They said three!
Three were still alive!
Okay.
He literally said three were still alive!
God, I hope they're breathing.
I hope they're breathing right now.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, don't worry.
Oh shit!
Oh fuck!
Don't worry!
Oh, I see him!
I see him still swimming!
I see him swimming!
Oh my god!
It's okay.
Okay, the ones that are on the ground are clearly dead.
I can see that.
I can see the dead bodies.
But it's okay.
There's all...
Oh!
Two, four, six, seven...
Wait, this one's alive!
This one!
They're just sleeping!
They're just...
Oh!
Oh, don't...
It's okay, one's alive!
Okay.
The sole survivor.
Alright.
Okay.
Let me turn up the heat a little bit more too.
Hello?
Okay, that's dead.
No, that...
No, he's definitely dead.
Oh!
He's alive!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, he's alive!
Master!
Oh, hello there!
Hello there!
My very much alive son!
My survivor!
You shall be called...
For surviving...
You shall be called Dragoon 1!
Wait, actually...
You will be my Dragoon...
For being the sole survivor...
Of your siblings.
My...
Wait, no!
Mimo!
You're right!
You shall be Mimo, just like Mimo!
You are the sole survivor of all the other dead fishes out there.
He is the chosen one.
Wait...
How do I...
Oh, they're just gone!
The bodies are just...
Is he alive?
Okay, he is alive.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, he is alive.
The siblings are dead dead.
They're...
They're both...
It's okay.
You're alive, though.
Good job.
I did not kill your brothers and sisters.
I...
I see it being a miracle.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wait, do I bring it to the snail?
Okay, to the...
Wait, there's...
Alright, let's bring him to...
Let's bring him to this guy.
He's a key...
What happened?
What?
Oh, he just...
How we live five minutes like...
Does he evolve?
Does he...
Wait, do I...
I...
Is he dead?
Does he...
Does he evolve at the shell?
He evolved into lunch.
He'll be fine, right?
Guys.
He's gonna be fine, right?
Right, guys?
Now it's being like, yoink.
My, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, wait.
Hello?
Are you gonna poop up my son?
I don't remember fighting me or anything like this.
Thank you for the super chat, reason.
Hello?
Can you poop him up?
For me.
Oh my god.
What do I do?
How long does this...
He's just evolving, right?
He's just...
Guys, he's just evolving, right?
He's still in there alive.
Right?
What?
Unlucky.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Donkey, maybe you're not meant to be taking care of the sea man after all.
Or any sea creatures.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Smelly, thank you for the super chat.
Guys.
Is he alive?
Is he alive in there?
He was supposed to be the strongest one out of all the children.
He survived five days without air.
What happened?
Get him out.
CPS.
Hi, Donkey.
We heard there was child abuse going on.
Wait, where's the kid?
Can't be child abuse if there's no more children in the tank.
Thank you for the super chat, Momo.
Thank you, thank you.
There's no way.
How am I doing it the way?
Oh my god, there must be evolution.
It must be evolution at work.
Right?
Wake up, little guy.
Wake up.
What if I advance time a little bit?
Just a little bit.
Don't worry, little guy.
I'll advance five more days.
Just wait.
Guys, no.
We don't need a restart.
How long do I have to wait?
Mr. Meat Boy.
Mr. Meat Boy, tell me.
How long?
Oh, one day.
Okay, don't worry.
I'll come back for you, child.
I'll come back.
Don't worry.
Okay.
Okay, one day.
It should be fine.
The tank should be fine after a day.
Right?
I believe.
Yes.
I believe they can survive after one day.
Well, good for you.
You get to watch one of them get eaten by a crab.
Alright.
Things will be fine.
Wait, was this...
Okay, everything will be fine.
One day.
One whole day.
Okay.
Mr. Meat Boy, I'm back.
I'm back, Mr. Meat Boy.
He'll be the...
If he lives, he'll be the strongest fish out there.
No fish...
No fish can challenge him.
It's called tough love.
What?
When the mushroomers emerge from the egg, use the right trigger to tap on the nautilus at the bottom of the tank.
If you continue to tap, the mushroomers will float toward the nautilus.
What happens next may surprise you.
He ate them!
He ate...
What?
He ate them!
It...
Was...
He...
Was he supposed to eat all of them?
I'm supposed to have...
I'm supposed to have more of them in him?
What do you mean?
What?
There should have been more?
What do you mean there should have been more?
Raza, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's not a challenge for you because there's no word chat.
I don't understand!
I...
He told me to feed the children!
Okay, clearly I need to feed more, right?
Alright.
Let me put... Wait, I don't have any more eggs.
Wait.
Whoops.
It'll go down, naturally.
Wait.
I need to press B to restart?
How do I restart?
Oh, I have to make a new save file?
I have to do... Goodbye, crap.
Goodbye.
I'm sorry, I couldn't save you.
How did I fuck up my Tamagotchi already?
Wait, did I kill them?
Wait, is he dead?
Wait, did I kill the crab?
How many did I kill?
I even killed...
What's wrong with me?
I've killed them all.
Oh my god, don't bring me back here.
Don't bring me back here.
Okay.
Get me out.
Okay, I figured it out.
This is a tank of death.
Oh my god!
He even died 0-9-0.
Good ratio.
But he ate one of them.
The Nautilus got to eat one of them.
Oh my god.
Was I just...
Was I just not meant to race Seaman?
Was I just never meant to race Seaman?
Oh, I actually pressed start.
God damn it!
Get me out of here!
I don't want to see my dead kids!
Get me!
Stop.
I don't want to see my dead children.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, here.
This is where I hold.
Do I have to restart my game?
Or like...
Or like, can I just do it here?
I'm holding B though.
This is my purgatory.
I am holding it!
It won't let me delete my save file!
I'm holding it!
Oh, hold B when you press start.
Oh!
I did that.
Did I do it?
Yeah?
Oh my god, I'm fucking trapped in my purgatory.
I'm trapped.
It won't let me...
It won't let me go.
It's not letting me go.
No!
Get me out of here!
I don't want to be here!
Okay.
Restart and hold B the entire time.
Okay, we gotta delete the save file.
Goodbye.
See you, man.
Is this one?
Okay.
Goodbye.
Like, it never happened.
It's like...
Guys, it's like it never happened, guys.
I... The children never existed.
If it never existed, I never killed any kids.
Guys.
If you think about it.
It's like it never happened.
I never...
I never... The children...
You see?
No memory of it ever happening.
No memory.
The stream just started for Seamad.
It's like it just happened, guys.
Guys.
Oh my god, I can't wait to try out Seamad for the very first time, guys.
I'm so excited.
I wonder what's... I wonder how the ink's gonna be hatched, guys.
I...
Oh, okay.
That's interesting, Mr. Memoy.
Oh, yeah.
How do they evolve?
I can't believe this game didn't outsell Super Mario 64.
Guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, my very first day, Mr. Memoy.
You're so right.
It is.
Mm-hmm.
Uh-huh.
Alright,
my very first time playing Seamad.
So how do I... I wonder... Oh my gosh.
I wonder how this game is gonna be like, guys.
I've always seen like videos and let's play of it.
Uh, so like... But I don't really remember much.
Alright, so... Oh, it's dark right now.
I guess I have to turn on the light?
How do I turn on the light?
Oh, there's the heater.
Oh, wait.
There's the light over there.
Oh, I guess I turn it on.
And then...
Also, like Mr. Memoy said, I have to turn on the air.
My... Wow, I'm learning so fast, guys!
Some would say I'm a natural at raising Seamad.
Man, I'm such a good listener!
Alright, let me put this up here.
I wish there was a faster way to get the air up.
It's so slow.
Oh my god.
It's actually incredibly slow.
Turning up the air.
Okay, what if I put... I'm gonna put the egg in right now.
I can't be bothered to wait for this.
Come on, pick it up.
There you go.
Now, heat it up too.
I'll just do the heating now.
Guys, this is my first time playing Seamad.
If it isn't, wouldn't I have like...
A save file for it already?
You know?
Wouldn't I have a previous memory...
Of me playing Seamad?
There wasn't any.
So clearly, this is my very first time playing it.
Okay, we'll get it at...
Where is it stopping?
17...
I wanna stop it at closer to 19 so I don't have to worry about...
I don't have to worry about like...
Him dying later.
Cause he'll never die, by the way.
Not that he will or anything.
Not that.
Airborne, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
More like, live freely and suffer.
Thank you for the super chat, Airborne.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, now that he's at 100% air...
He's gonna start growing now, right?
Okay, so like...
When they hatch...
When he hatches...
Do I have to actually wait 5 days?
Or like...
Can they get eaten up like instantly?
Still doesn't need food.
This is their food.
Right here.
No?
That part comes later?
Okay, so I'll check him tomorrow.
I...
Good man.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Don't worry, he'll be fine.
No, just...
No, no, wait.
Day by day is good.
Okay, I'll check up on you tomorrow.
Okay?
Okay.
I'm gonna wait for you to hatch.
And then I'll check up on you guys tomorrow.
So don't die on me.
I don't...
I believe in these little guys to definitely live tomorrow.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm very much looking forward to watching Tokibert playing Seaman for the very first time.
I sure hope that egg has a long and fruitful life.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you so much for all the Akasupas.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you for the support, man.
Interesting man.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hey Doki, just my pet fish a month ago and finally got over it.
Checking your stream this year.
What's this game about?
Oh, you know, this is my very first time raising Seaman.
I'm gonna make sure all these kids live for at least another day.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Zero, thank you for the super chat.
Another episode of Collective Amnesia.
What are you talking about?
I have only one memory of raising Seaman and it's this one.
There's no other file.
I only have one file of the children.
And they're all still alive.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Come on, they're supposed to hatch any moment now.
Come on, hatch.
Hatch, little guys.
Come on.
Hatch up so you can get eaten by this guy.
Hatch up.
Oh, there they are.
Come on, little guys.
Right here.
Come on.
Right here, guys.
It's food time.
Come on.
Dinner time.
Right here.
The miracle of birth just happened.
Where did they go?
Where did they all go?
Oh, there they are.
Oh my, there they are.
Right here.
All of you.
All of you, get over here.
Right here.
That's right.
Get over here.
Every single one of you.
The miracle of childbirth right here.
Come on.
There we go.
One.
Come on.
We need another one.
One.
Come on.
Aren't you hungry, little guy?
Aren't you hungry?
Okay.
One.
Come on.
Oh, oh, oh.
No, you're still hungry.
Aren't you still hungry?
Two.
Okay.
Alright.
How much more to go?
Okay.
Two.
Come on.
You're still hungry, aren't you?
Aren't you?
Three.
Are you still hungry?
Oh, whoa, whoa.
Alright.
Three.
Come on.
Four.
Go, go.
Oh.
So hungry.
How hungry are you, big boy?
Five.
That's right.
Come on.
Don't you want to eat more?
Yes, you do.
I can give you all the kids you want.
Five, six.
Yum, yum, yum.
Oh, wait.
I lost count.
It's actually seven.
Yum, yum, yum.
One last chance.
Yum, yum, yum, yum.
Get more.
Yes!
There we go.
We did it.
Alright.
That should be it, right?
Now he ate all the kids.
Are you satisfied?
What happened to him?
Wait, is he dying?
Oh, wait.
No, okay.
He's fine.
Okay.
He's fine now.
Alright, nice.
We did it.
We fed all the kids.
Yeah.
We did it.
Oh, so what's gonna happen now?
Like, what do I do now?
So, now that all the kids are gone...
What happens now?
Do I have to wait a day?
Okay, let me put it at 20.
All the kids are dead, so...
I don't know.
I didn't think this far.
It won't even let me, like, expand out.
Do you think he'll be okay?
10 minutes?
Okay, so what if I just time skip 10 minutes right now?
No, he's not dead yet.
Look, he's still okay.
See?
Look.
He's right there.
He's having a good time.
He's okay, guys.
Look.
See?
He's just having a swimming time.
Look, he's floating up.
He wants to see what the sun is like.
But little does he know, he's trapped in the lab forever.
You're never gonna see sunlight, little guy.
You're just gonna be part of our sick little experiments for science.
That's right.
You're never gonna see what the sun will look like.
This is your whole life now.
You live and die in this tank.
Just for our sick pleasure.
You like the artificial light to simulate sunlight for you?
Yeah, you like it?
No, he's fine.
Look at him.
He's just swimming.
He's just swimming, guys.
He's fine.
Look at him.
He's having a great time.
What happened to you?
I literally just saw 7 of my kids die from freezing and lack of air.
And then the 8th child got eaten by him.
But it all happened in my dream.
I had like a Final Destination premonition of it.
You know, like the Final Destination vision that you have?
And all of that happened.
And anyway, this is the very first time I'm playing this game.
This is my very first run, guys.
Right here.
Crazy.
It was a crazy dream.
Nervous.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You 100% put your sims in a portal.
Delete the ladder.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, I've done some...
Okay.
I've done some fucked up shit in Sims.
And I was like...
I was like...
Oh.
What's going on?
Are you okay?
Oh my god.
He's freaking out.
Wait, I know what to do.
I know what to do.
Guys, I know what to do.
I just need to pick it up.
Guys.
Guys, I know what to do.
Come on.
Come on, pick it up.
He's hungry.
Come on.
Oh, there you go.
There you go.
I got food.
Guys, food will heal you.
Oh, it's spitting out.
Oh, look.
Look, there's food right there.
I have food right there.
Don't worry.
Are you okay?
That's not vomit, right?
That's not blood, right?
Just some cranberry juice that you ingested?
You okay, buddy?
Hello?
I got food.
I put food in there.
Sharko, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wish I was that squid.
Someone, do we have a fish doctor?
He has a heart attack.
Any fish doctors right now in chat?
What do I do?
Why can't he just die instantly?
Why is he suffering?
Why is he...
Oh my god.
No, he's still alive.
Holy shit.
What the fuck is this game?
I just thought it was funny talking haha fish.
Why am I watching a squid slowly fucking die?
This is so messed up.
Hello?
Oh my god, you can see his intestines.
What the...
What the fuck am I...
I'm a mother.
Oh my god, Giles.
I'm a mommy now.
I'm a mother.
Holy shit.
What do I do?
Do I...
Do I give him food?
Oh, okay.
Like...
Mom, we need you.
Master, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Arisa, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
There's no way this game was for children.
I refuse to believe they made this game for kids.
There's no fucking way.
Okay, how do I use the mic?
What button do I have to press to talk to them?
I want to talk to this one in particular.
This does not seem like a children's game.
What button do I have to press on the controller?
Because I heard that you have to press a...
You have to hold a certain button.
He's looking at me as if like...
Hello?
I don't know if it's working, guys.
Talk to me!
Hello?
Am I allowed to talk to them yet?
Children!
Hello?
Do babies talk?
Baby!
That's right, baby!
I'm talking to you!
Baby!
How do I feed them?
I can't...
Oh my god, they're so...
I can't feed them anymore!
I already have one right here, but they don't want to eat it!
Eat here!
Eat!
Eat, baby!
No, baby!
Eat here!
Eat!
Eat, babies!
Eat over here!
Food!
They're not hungry, guys.
They're not.
What do I do now?
What do you eat?
What do you fuckers eat?
Eat!
Food!
Just...
Okay, it's time.
Yes.
I'll come back tomorrow.
I'll come back in three... Okay, I'll come back in three hours.
Because I feel like if I come back tomorrow, the children will die.
I'm gonna come back... I'm gonna come back in three hours.
Okay.
Two hours.
I don't trust... I don't...
I just don't trust... I don't trust Mr. Nemo.
I...
This really is a genuine prequel.
Zero, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Cyclone, thank you for the super chat.
Alright.
What is Mr. Nemo gonna tell me now?
I feel like I was being a really good parent.
I was being an incredibly great parent there.
Yeah, I saved my second visit, guys.
Okay.
I did that.
But please be careful.
Do not give them too much at once, as their appetites are insatiable.
So let us head over to the tank.
Wait, how much do I have to give them?
Per day?
Wait, how much food do I have to give them per day, then?
For my Gilman?
How much is enough?
Oh, wait, they ate it!
They ate it!
Look, it's gone!
It's gone!
I did my job!
Okay.
Look, it's gone!
Hello, my children.
I am here now.
Hello!
Hello, children!
I'm here now.
Hello!
Children!
Hello?
They just...
Hello, children?
Hello?
I was not with...
They turned back!
Hello?
Children, hello?
Hello, children?
Hello?
Talk to me!
I am your mother!
Hello?
Oh my God!
Oh my God, they said hi!
They said hi!
Oh my God!
They said their first words!
Hello!
Kids!
They actually talked!
Oh my God!
Did you hear it?
He said mama!
They said number one mama!
But never killed their children.
Oh my God, they're so smart.
Already said their first sentence.
I know, you might not have heard it, but I heard it.
I've heard it, guys.
I heard it, though.
Let's give them more food.
Okay.
Here you go.
I got more food for you kids.
I got you more food.
Look, right here.
Right here.
Food!
Eat food!
Do you want food?
Baby!
Baby want food?
Child!
Food!
Does baby want food?
I'm trying!
I'm trying to get him to talk!
Food!
Oh, you don't like that.
You don't like that, do you?
You don't...
Bro is not listening.
Okay, okay.
Okay, he doesn't like food.
Alright, I'm coming back.
How long does it take for them to grow, guys?
How long does it take for these guys to grow?
Guys, how long?
Oh my god, what the fuck?
How long does it take for them to grow?
One day at a time?
I'm coming back tomorrow!
Tomorrow!
Alright, Gilman?
I come back!
Tomorrow!
Okay, okay.
I think they understand.
Next day!
I'll be back.
Don't worry, children.
Okay, let me make sure that everything is okay right now.
Peter, let's put that at 19 for now.
Yeah, I'm putting that there.
Alright, I'm coming back tomorrow!
Tomorrow!
Is it even working?
It's gotta work!
It's working!
It is!
I believe in it!
Okay.
Okay, then we...
We come back the next day.
Okay.
It should work.
It says it works.
I wonder what...
Okay, it should be like stereo.
Okay.
Okay, tomorrow.
I'm gonna put that at 8am.
The next day.
Okay.
It'll be okay.
It's technically tomorrow.
My little seaman.
Alright.
A little time travel wouldn't hurt anybody.
Good
morning.
Welcome to the laboratory of Jean-Paul Gasset.
Greetings, and welcome back.
You're doing a good job.
Let's see.
Did you hear the noises that young man was making?
Yeah!
It seems as if he's trying to speak.
You can use your microphone to speak to him as well.
Do not forget to press the A button while you're speaking into the microphone.
Okay, it's A.
Oh no!
Oh my god, wait!
I didn't raise the heater!
Don't worry!
Kids!
Oh, oh.
Don't worry.
We're...
Okay, don't worry kids.
Don't worry kids.
I got you!
Kids, I got you!
I'm raising the heat!
Wake up!
It's so warm now!
Okay.
That should be good.
And then the air.
Okay, and then you guys can breathe.
Breathe, my children!
Breathe!
It's okay, it's just a little hot.
It's just a little bit.
It's okay.
It's just a little bit hot, guys.
Alright.
And now they can breathe too.
Okay.
And then...
It's okay.
It'll go down.
It's gonna go down anyway.
Okay, and then we give you food.
Take the food, children!
Where's the food?
Oh wait, where did the food go?
Okay, there you go.
Take the food, children!
What?
Why ain't no grab?
Oh, there you go.
There you go.
Eat, my children!
Eat!
Eat the food!
Keep eating!
Did they eat it?
I can't tell.
Did they eat the food?
Oh, it's gone.
Did all of them eat though?
Did you all eat the food?
Okay, I need to figure out if the microphone's not...
I don't think the microphone...
I don't know if the microphone is actually working.
Do I give them another one?
I'll give them another one just in case.
Okay.
Here you go.
Here's another food for the ones that couldn't.
No, it's okay, it's just one guide.
Look, see, none of them are eating.
None of them are eating it too.
Hello!
Guys, I don't think it's working.
Wait!
Mr. Nimoy!
Hello!
Wait, he's looking!
He's looking!
Is he looking at me?
I'm holding A.
Hello?
Are you stupid?
He's like, no!
No!
He looks so confused.
The fuck you say?
Wait, what if I talk to him?
Hello!
Oh, wait!
They're acknowledging me!
Hello!
Hello, look at me!
Look at me, I am your mother!
Look at me!
I am your mother!
Show me your face!
You stupid son!
Look at me!
You haven't hit your puberty stage yet!
I need you to look at me!
Look at me!
You're not stupid!
I was joking!
Please, look at me!
There's eight of you!
You know I need to pick one in the end.
There has to be a favorite child.
There's eight of you.
Don't you want to be the favorite child?
Don't you want to be a favorite child, little guy?
Hello!
Okay,
wait.
I don't know if the microphone is actually working, guys.
I can't tell.
I actually cannot tell.
I'm holding A, but I can't tell if the microphone is actually working.
I can't tell at all.
Alright.
I'll give it a couple of hours, because I feel like they'll freeze if I use, like...
Like, what?
I guess, like...
Wait, baby!
Okay, wait.
Let me invite her.
Baby!
Hello!
Hello, baby!
Baby!
Look at me!
Hello!
They stopped talking to me!
Baby fish!
Hello!
Baby!
They stopped talking!
They used to talk to me, and then they stopped talking to me, guys!
What happened?!
Why don't they talk to me no more?!
I don't understand!
They hate me.
What did I do?!
I've been nothing but kind to my children!
I don't understand!
I've been so nice to my kids!
Why are they...
Why are they so stupid?!
I don't understand!
Hello!
They used to respond to me!
Respond to me!
Why don't you talk to me?!
Look at me!
They know what they did to you.
They know what you did to your brothers.
No, it works!
It should work!
Okay, alright.
We wait a couple of hours.
I'll be back, children.
I'll be back.
Don't worry.
Okay.
Wait, let me fix... make sure the air is up.
Make sure the air and the...
I need to make sure they don't die.
The most important part.
I gotta make sure they don't die.
Okay, I'll be back in a couple of hours, children.
Don't worry.
I'll be back, little ones.
I'll be back until you grow big and strong.
Do not worry.
Okay.
I'll give a couple of hours.
I don't trust...
I don't trust, like, the next day.
Because I literally put a couple of hours.
And then, Mr. Nimoy was like, Your fish is dying.
Whoops.
He was like, Your fish is freezing.
And I'm like, what?
What do you mean they're freezing?
How are they...
How are they freezing?
I left for, like, a couple of hours.
Okay.
That should be fine.
They should still be alive.
They should still be alive, right?
I'm back now, kids.
I'm back.
I've been with them for at least five minutes every time.
Every couple... Every day.
That's enough love for these fishes.
Okay, they should be alive.
Hello, Mr. Nimoy.
Are they alive?
Are my children alive?
Yeah.
Okay.
Okay, they're still alive.
See?
Look, they're like...
You don't have to keep coming back.
But they're always suffering from the cold.
They're always cold.
They're like, stop giving them attention.
Then stop fucking making it so cold.
They always have to be there to fucking raise the temperature for these fuckers.
I mean, the children that I love.
Okay.
Children that I love and raise to their full potential.
Don't worry, kids.
That's okay.
Are you guys happier now, my kids?
Kids.
Don't worry, it's at 19.4.
Why are you- Oh, one degree is higher.
Oh my- Grow up, kids.
Grow the fuck up right now.
Alright, there you go.
How are you guys crying?
It was literally 0.1 degree higher.
Children.
Why are you guys being little bitches right now?
I did not raise little bitches.
Don't keep their poor- Alright, nice.
Alright.
Hello, little one.
Hello.
Okay, let me check the microphone thing real quick.
Sound.
Okay, no, not that.
Okay.
Let me double check.
Which one would it be at?
Is it video?
I don't remember.
Oh, it's control.
Right?
No.
Which one is it?
Which one would it be?
Okay.
No, I did buy an A.
No, I did.
Okay, give me a sec.
I'm trying to remember how to do this.
Oh no, yeah, it is on microphone.
Okay.
Yeah, it is.
I have it on microphone.
Controller.
A.
Yeah!
Okay.
Hello.
Hello?
Don't ignore me.
Baby!
Give me a sec, I need to use the bathroom.
I need to use the bathroom.
These kids are...
These children.
Why don't these children talk to me?
I do so much!
Microphone.
I don't understand!
I do so much for them!
I don't understand.
I do so much.
Oh my god!
Okay, I have to run as admin.
Okay, I'll be back.
Wait, let me feed you guys.
I mean, run as admin on my Dreamcast.
For, so that...
I mean, my screen...
My capture device.
Yeah, that's what...
I have to run it on my capture device, guys.
There we go.
Wow.
What do you mean?
I literally fed them!
How much more do these fuckers need?
I like, gave them food and love.
By screaming at them.
Alright.
Okay.
Don't worry, little ones.
I shall communicate with you.
I will communicate with you kids.
If it's the last thing I do.
Do not worry.
Child.
You shall be communicated.
I will do my best.
I need to be able to tell my kids.
What I want them to do.
I should be allowed to.
How else would the kids know any better, guys?
How else would they know any better if I can't talk to them?
The time setting of the Dreamcast internal clock does not match the time setting of your Seaman Habitat file.
The time setting of the Dreamcast internal clock may be incorrect.
Please adjust it if necessary.
Guys, what was it?
Do you remember what it was?
Does anyone remember what it was?
I don't remember what I put it on.
It was...
What was it?
Guys, what was it?
I don't remember.
What was it for?
Okay.
Time.
What was the time?
Guys.
Surely somebody remembers the time.
Surely.
It was...
I don't remember.
He knows.
Mr. Nimoy knows.
Okay, you're right.
The file.
You're right.
4...
Okay, we were all wrong.
It was 4.05.16.43.
Okay.
4.05.
4.05.16.
Okay, it's like I traveled an hour.
I traveled a couple of hours.
There we go.
Save.
Guys, we saved it.
We saved it.
He'll never know.
He'll never know, guys.
He didn't caught me.
He didn't catch me, guys.
Oh, I forgot the...
Guys, I forgot the year.
I forgot to do the...
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Guys, guys.
He still has yet to catch me.
He hasn't caught me yet.
Okay, there we go.
Hasn't caught me.
No, no, no.
Still hasn't caught me.
There we go.
Never caught...
It's okay.
He doesn't know.
Mr. Nimoy doesn't know.
Hello, Mr. Nimoy.
I'm back.
Time Cop hasn't caught me yet.
I'm still there.
Okay.
Am I in the clear?
This is your fourth visit today.
You visit often.
If one didn't know better, one might assume you're quite obsessed.
Or you have nothing better to do.
Is that true?
At the moment...
I'm just trying to make sure they don't die.
You men...
They are enjoying a comfortable environment.
Oh, see.
It's very comfortable.
So, let us head over to the tent.
Yeah.
He's saying it's very comfortable, guys.
They enjoy it.
They enjoy their time.
Okay, let's check the...
Check the usual...
Okay, 100.
Okay.
Hello!
Baby!
Yes!
Hello!
Do you see me?
Speak!
Speak to me, child!
Please!
Speak to me!
Oh my god.
Okay, we give them food.
Maybe if I give them food, they'll speak to me.
You know?
Will they speak now?
Hello!
Children!
Is feeding them three times not good?
They're not...
They're not fat.
Perfectly good weight.
Children!
Hello!
I hate raising kids.
These kids...
They're so...
They don't know what's good for them.
They take things for granted.
I am trying my best to raise them.
But do they care?
Hello!
Do any of you care?
Do you care?
Do you?
Hello!
Talk to me!
Baby!
I brought you into this world, baby!
How come before they were talking to me, they were like...
No, no, no.
They were like...
They were like moving their heads back and forth!
Hello!
They're like...
You talking to me?
They like moved their heads back and forth!
They like acknowledged me at one point and now they don't?
They don't even care about me anymore!
Why don't you care?
I don't...
I don't understand.
I don't care.
Hello!
You!
Baby!
Fish!
Kill man!
Man!
I can't...
They hate me.
I'll come back tomorrow.
These fucking kids.
Maybe they'll talk to me tomorrow, guys.
Maybe...
Maybe they'll talk to me tomorrow!
I believe.
Maybe tomorrow is that day that they decided to talk to me.
Okay, I need to make sure if it's correct.
Okay, yeah.
Alright.
At 5 AM.
That's right, mom's coming back home at 5 in the morning.
Mom's back.
She'll keep coming back until you fucking talk to her.
She'll keep coming back!
She'll never leave until you talk to me!
That's all I want!
I'm not erratic!
I just love them very much!
I just love my children!
I love all 8 of them!
Why is he calling me out?
I just want to make sure they grow up nice, big, and strong!
Okay.
Oh my god.
They're fucking complaining about how cold it is.
I'm doing my best, children.
Um...
I literally came back- I'm here at 5 in the morning, children.
Why are you complaining?
How are they dying?
I came back at 5 in the morning and then Nemo was like, Why do you keep coming back?
I don't know, because my kids keep fucking dying, I guess.
Okay.
Air time.
And then they need to breathe, too.
I'm not overfeeding them.
They're fine.
Look at them.
I feed them 3 times a day.
Breakfast, lunch, and dinner.
That's like adequate feed time.
They're not- They're not even talking to me.
They're just complaining.
They're complaining at me, not talking to me.
It's like when you wake up and you're like, Mom, I'm hungry.
Yeah?
How was your day?
And then they come back from school and it's like, Mom!
Mom!
I want food!
And then I'm like, what?
You don't want to tell me about the day you had?
How was school?
Oh, you don't want to mention how school was?
All you want to do is fucking demand food?
That's the kids right now.
That's them.
Anyway.
Child.
Baby.
Hello?
Oh!
Wait!
Baby!
Gilman!
Oh!
Talk!
Wait.
Wait, he's like...
Is he trying to talk to me?
Was that...
Was that him?
I don't know.
I can't tell.
Is he looking around because he wants to talk to me?
Hello?
Little child.
I can't tell if he's reacting to me.
He says...
Fuck off.
He's telling you to go away.
I can't tell!
Ma!
That weird cat is back.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, let me give him food.
Wait, will I get more food later?
Am I...
Do they not replenish my food?
Wait.
I don't know.
Wait, they don't?
Oh!
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Sorry, no food for now.
Sorry, no food.
Apparently, you guys don't get more food.
Oh, I did not realize it's limited.
I...
Hello!
I don't know if they care.
I don't know.
Hello!
Hello?
Why do you keep shaking your head?
Speak!
Get all mad.
Don't look at me like that!
I'm your fucking mother!
Don't give me that face!
Speak, yo man!
Speak!
Oh my god, and he fucking walked away.
You can't pick them up!
I tried!
All I can do is do this!
I can tickle them!
I'm giving them a little tickle!
You like that little tickle?
Yeah, do you like that?
Oh, you like that, you little fucking...
You like that?
I can...
Yeah, I can't grab them.
All I can do is just...
That's all I can do.
I can give them little tickles.
That's right.
The tickle time!
Woah, woah, woah!
That's right, little tickle time!
How do I drag them?
No, I can't.
I definitely cannot drag them.
Alright.
I can't do anything else right now.
Okay, I'm coming back in a couple of hours.
How long does it take for them to grow, guys?
So they can actually talk to me.
How long does it take for them to grow?
Wait, right trigger plus X?
Wait, right trigger...
No?
Nope.
It doesn't let me grab.
Oh, oh!
Can he die?
What the fuck?
What the fuck am I doing?
That's right, suffocate.
What the fuck?
That's right.
Cry.
That's what you get for not speaking to your mother.
Speak to your mother!
That's right, speak to me!
Alright, there you go.
Now they'll know.
No, he's not.
He's fine.
Look at him, he's okay.
Oh, no, he's okay.
He's breathing.
Oh, thank God he's breathing.
Oh, he's...
Look, see, he's okay, guys.
See, look.
Look, he's okay.
He's okay, guys.
He's okay, he's okay, he's okay.
I didn't...
I didn't accidentally kill anybody.
He's okay, everyone.
He's okay.
Alright.
I'll feed you guys later.
I am gonna make sure...
I'm coming back in a couple of hours, children.
Do not worry.
I'm coming back in a couple of hours, babies.
You'll be fine.
We'll be fine.
Okay.
And a 10.
How long does it take for them to grow?
I have no idea.
I can't tell how long it takes for these kids to grow.
It feels like...
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Somebody said, like, weeks, and then I was like...
I was like...
There's no way.
Good morning.
See,
they're fine.
They're fine.
They're fine, the kids are still okay.
I picked one up, and all I did was give it emotional trauma.
But other than that, the kids are alright.
They seem to be reacting positively to my care.
Which is good to know.
Okay.
Oh, everything is still okay, that's good.
Hello.
Baby.
When he said hello back, where the fuck is he?
Is he in the void?
Where did you swim to?
Oh, my God.
Wait, did he respond back?
I said hello.
Okay.
Do I feed them now?
They evolve.
Do I get more food or no?
Or is this all the food I'm gonna get for the rest of their lives?
When they evolve, do I not get more?
Oh.
Okay.
Alright, I'm gonna evolve you guys again.
Oh, that's awkward.
I'll come back for you guys soon.
That's a little awkward.
That's fine.
Okay.
Come back here.
That should be enough time for them to grow, right?
I don't know how many days it's been for these children now.
How long have I been taking care of them?
I feel like...
I've like lost track of how long I've been taking care of them.
It feels like I've been taking care of them for years now.
There's no way it's been one day.
Three?
Okay, one more day and then they'll finally move out, right?
One more day and then my Gilman will move out, right guys?
Surely.
Yeah.
I'm trying my best!
They keep being cold!
Okay.
Do I need a... How many times do I have to feed them?
Do I have to feed them per day or can I like not feed them after a while?
Okay, let's see.
Air.
It's still good.
Air is still good.
That's good to know.
What about heat?
One per day?
Okay, it's time.
It's feeding time, my little children.
Hello!
I fucking hate my kids.
I don't feed them?
Did I not feed them?
I didn't feed them yesterday.
I thought I did!
I don't remember.
Guys, I don't remember if I fed them or not.
I don't...
They can starve a little, fuck it.
You're right.
Goodbye, kids.
They can starve a little bit.
It's fine.
I'll see you tomorrow, children.
I'll see you tomorrow.
I'll visit you at exactly midnight.
I'll feed them at midnight.
That's good enough.
Alright, don't worry.
I'm back, kids.
I feel like it's a new day.
It's time to eat.
It's time to eat, children.
It's a new day.
I am?
Oh, there's still eight.
They're always cold.
When are they not cold?
They always demand me to fucking fix the heat.
Are they paying the bills for this heater?
No, they're not.
Oh my god, why are you crying?
Are you the one that's trying to fucking make the ends meet right now trying to care for eight kids?
I'm a fucking single mother.
Your dad died.
You fucking ate his inside out and now he's dead.
Like, what the fuck am I supposed to do?
Oh, now they're complaining it's too hot.
It's too hot.
They literally killed their father.
We all saw it.
And nobody helped him.
I asked if there was a fish doctor and nobody came and helped him.
We all watched him die.
Alright.
It's a hundred.
Now you guys can breathe.
Alright.
Can I feed them now?
Hello, little guys.
Are you guys growing?
You're not even growing.
I'm supposed to feed them after midnight.
Imagination art.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Are you hungry?
Let me know.
Do you need food?
Hello?
Fish?
Food?
Hungry?
Goodbye, kids.
I'll give you food when it's morning.
Stop insisting on the food.
But when do I feed them?
If I don't feed them now, when do I feed them?
Okay, it's 8am.
Now you feed.
Now you get food, right?
They're not orphans.
I'm still alive.
How are they orphans when I'm still here?
Okay, I'll feed them here.
If anything, I'm gonna be a...
If anything, I won't be a mother soon.
Okay.
Okay, wait until they say he's hungry.
Okay, I'll wait there.
Great, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Dad died.
Yes, we were all there.
We all saw him die.
In fact, he even suffered.
He 100% suffered too.
Okay, they're still fine.
Alright.
I'm not even gonna look at you guys.
I'll be back.
I just look at them and be like, see ya.
You're alive.
Alright, I'm leaving.
As long as you're alive, I get to leave.
Alright.
I'm just checking if they're alive.
At this point.
Mero, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
If you need more food, you can use a few semen as rations.
Survival of the fittest.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, nobody died.
Bye.
Come back when you fucking evolve, my little fishies.
Oh, don't worry.
They're not getting that much.
Again?!
At least they're not hungry.
When do you evolve?!
Evolve and move out!
When will you evolve?!
Why, boy?
Welcome to tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
It's okay.
We heat them up.
They're not dead yet.
Okay, is that good enough?
I'll do a little bit more.
Nice.
Okay, just perfect.
And then we give them air.
Accidentally, I'm thanking you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, and then we give them air.
Air!
Alright.
When will you be... When will you go to college?
When?
Go to college.
Move out.
Move out!
When?!
Become doctor!
Doctor!
I'll come back soon and then maybe you'll be doctor.
Red, welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Give me a sec.
Let me turn the time up.
You can't say that.
It's your fault that I don't have a good childhood.
Because someone couldn't keep it in their past.
It's your fault!
The dad died!
Maybe if you didn't kill the father, I would be a happier person.
Alright.
How's the kids?
Oh, it's my fourth visit?
He keep freezing!
I have to keep visiting!
How do you still not evolve?
It's three days!
How are they still tiny?
Are you still tiny?
They're still tiny.
It's because they keep fucking... I keep having to put it at 20 because they'll freeze.
Hello.
Killed your father and now I resent you for the rest of my life.
Okay, bye.
I always need to remind the children that it's their fault.
Alright.
Now a couple of hours next.
Okay.
Surely they're not dead yet, right?
The next day.
Okay, this is day three.
This is day three now.
What happens if you do one day?
We did one day and then the tank was empty.
Next day, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
This game is discriminating against people with short attention spans.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Red.
No, it was inspired by PewDiePie playing Seaman ten plus years ago.
And that game lived right free in my head for the longest fucking time.
I didn't even realize other people played it.
I just remember watching PewDiePie play it.
They're always cold!
Okay.
Guys, there is no way I'm playing this in real time.
I do not...
There is no way I could ever play this in real time.
I don't even have time.
I even time traveled in Animal Crossing on the GameCube.
Alright.
Maybe evolved you can stop freezing to death.
Stop crying!
I fucking put it at 20 degrees plus every time and you've lived.
At this point your skin should have adapted to the hotness.
Alright.
Now you can breathe.
Alright, there we go.
Are you guys happy now?
Okay, fucker, I'm leaving.
Okay, I'm leaving after that.
Alright.
Fucking ungrateful little brats.
They actually was like, no!
Fucking little shits.
Uh, Taquita, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I am giving so much love, care, and attention.
I come in there and be like...
Are you cold?
And are you breathing?
You are?
Okay, I leave.
It is good to have you back so soon.
At the moment, the habitat contains eight human.
I have to grab them at least once a day?
They do not need that much love.
I'll pick one.
One won't be lucky enough.
Okay, let's see...
Alright, who's the lucky one?
You!
Yes, hello!
Oh, don't get out!
Don't get out!
That's right!
Whoa!
Oh, whoops.
Oh, that's...
Whoops, I did not mean that.
That's right!
Om nom nom!
Put you in my mouth!
Om nom nom nom!
You!
Alright.
That's enough love now.
That was too much love.
Oh, that's enough love for the whole year, guys.
My intrusive thoughts keep being like, what if I...
What if I just won't?
Oh, goodbye!
Don't get out!
What if I just...
I did it, okay?
I already spent so much time raising these fuckers.
Please, I just want to see them evolve!
Hello.
Yeah, are they... are they...
Are they grown-ups now?
Again?!
When will you be big?!
When?!
It's been three days!
Okay.
It's okay.
I'm giving you more heat.
I'm giving them so much heat.
You'll be nice and warm now.
Okay, and then where's the air?
There it is.
Alright.
Now you can...
Now you get air.
They're so talk... Now they're so talk... They're always talkative when they want to complain!
Alright, children.
My chat wants me to visit you next and give you less attention, which is crazy, because I feel like...
I feel like I was giving just the right amount, but apparently I need to give even less.
So I guess I grab you real quick?
Alright, let's be... Let me grab you real quick.
Come on, let me grab you.
Oh, you thought you could run away?
You thought you could run away?
I have eight kids.
What's one... Maybe if I have one less, it'd be fine.
Alright, goodbye children.
You're not starving too, so it's fine.
I haven't fed you in two days, so it's okay.
Yeah, exactly.
One less mouth to feed?
Sounds like the dream.
Alright, we start visiting them twice a day, starting now.
Alright.
This is once.
Oh, wait.
Nine.
There we go.
It starts now.
We get less visits.
Less visitation rights.
Mama's on parole right now.
That means less visitation rights to see the kids.
Thank fucking god.
They'll cannibalize each other if you're not careful though.
Whoa!
Don't fucking give me hope there.
Greetings, and welcome back.
You're doing a good job.
At the moment, the habitat contains eight young men.
They are suffering from the cold.
Please use the heater to raise the temperature to a more comfortable level.
So let us head over to the tank.
They're still suffering from the cold?
When will you not suffer from the cold?
Okay.
Are they still suffering from- I don't understand.
How are you still cold?
Oh my god, I think the worst part is that the heater takes fucking forever.
It takes so long!
Die!
Oh my god, I wish it turns up faster.
Why don't I have this on automatic?
Okay, they're gonna burn a little bit, but that's alright.
That's alright.
Alright.
Okay, when will you guys start eating each other for the next evolution line?
Alright, 79, 80.
100.
Come on, give me that 100!
Come on!
Can I actually, like, cook them and they'll die?
Like, if I actually, like, just leave it on at, like, 50 degrees, do they actually start cooking?
I'm curious.
Alright, I apparently need to grab one of you guys every day.
I pick you.
That's right, little guy!
Wow, yeah?
That's right, are you having fun breathing oxygen?
Oh my god, yummy, yummy oxygen!
Okay.
Leave now.
I'm waiting for you guys to eat each other.
I can still wait.
I will wait.
I'll keep waiting until you eat each other.
And then I'll be happy.
Okay.
My second visit.
Alright, second visit.
Starting now.
Alright, are they still alive?
Oh, they have to do the thing?
But they didn't do it when I'm there.
Okay.
Alright.
The last one that doesn't get eaten will actually... and I'll say that I love you.
The one that eats all of them, I'll give you my love.
Hello.
Welcome to the laboratory of Jean-Paul Gasset.
This is your second visit today.
It is good to have you back so...
soon.
Is this day three?
As always, is there anything new?
Alright, it's time!
Is this day four?
Alright guys, I'm staying here to watch you eat each other.
It's time.
Alright, the moment we get there, I'm ready.
To watch the feeding.
The great feeding.
Alright, you know what?
This is fine.
And then we'll give you some air so you'll... at least your brain can breathe a little bit when you eat each other.
Alright guys, mama's here to watch the great feeding.
No wonder you guys aren't hungry.
Alright, mama's here.
The one that lives actually gets mama's love.
What do you mean I have to speak English?
I have to tell them to speak English?
The fuck does that mean?
Alright, eat each other.
Get over here.
Alright.
English!
English.
I don't know.
English!
English or Spanish?
Okay.
I had to click on one of them?
English!
Speak English!
Guys, I don't think...
Oh my god, I fucking hate my kids.
They hate my children.
I hate them.
Oh my god, why are they like this?
Why the fuck are they like this?
What do I...
Please just eat each other.
Please.
Hello!
Fish!
Why did they ignore me?
Oh, tickle, tickle, tickle, tickle, tickle, tickle.
Tickle, tickle, tickle.
Yeah, cry.
Tickle, tickle!
Speak!
Okay.
Why are they not eating each other?
It's day four.
I was promised...
I was promised that you start cannibalizing each other.
I was promised food.
I am not absolutely sure my mic is working.
I am not absolutely sure, guys.
So I do not know.
Wow.
I don't understand.
Do I have... Oh my God, I don't understand.
Why are they not speaking?
I don't understand.
Please, speak to me!
Okay, let me look at this real quick.
Maybe if I look at this...
Okay.
I'm looking at this guide.
I just...
Please, why don't you speak to me?
I've done so much for you!
Like...
I was promised!
I was promised cannibalism!
Speak!
Fish!
Speak to me!
Why don't you speak?
Wow!
Okay, that's freaky.
Oh my God.
Hello?
Why don't you evolve?
Evolve!
E-V-O-L-V-E Just evolve.
Please!
I just want you to evolve.
Evolve!
Oh my God!
Why won't they evolve?
Why?
Evolve!
Speak!
Fish!
I'm holding the button!
E-V-O-L-V-E Please!
Be calm down!
Please move out of my home!
Fish!
Please!
Become big!
Leave my home!
One of them will evolve, surely.
Surely.
Fish!
Hello!
Hello, fish!
I was promised catabolism!
Why do I not get catabolism?
I'm so sad.
Why won't...
Why won't you catabolize each other?
Catabolism!
Eat!
I need them to eat each other!
I need you to evolve!
I don't want this filament anymore!
I can eat an egg goon if it makes you feel better.
It's not the same.
Next scene.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I don't understand!
Why won't they eat each other?
I waited so long!
It's three days!
This batch of children!
There's something wrong with them!
Fish!
There's something wrong with these kids!
They won't talk to me!
They won't eat each other!
They won't evolve!
We're at day four!
I was told they start eating each other at day three!
Why are they still here?
Why?
Eat!
Fish!
Why are you still here like this?
Why?
I don't understand.
How are you still here like this?
Why?
Why can't you...
Why can't you eat your siblings?
That's all I wanted from you.
That's all I wanted.
I want you to eat your siblings.
Eat!
Is that...
Okay.
Okay, I got an idea.
I got an idea.
Guys.
Guys, I got an idea.
I figured it out.
Okay, we gotta remember the date.
Okay, it's...
Look at this.
Okay, I gotta save this.
I figured it out, guys.
I figured it out.
I know what to do.
I will make sure it works.
I will make sure...
I will make sure this works.
Okay.
This is it.
This is my Hail Mary.
This is...
Come on.
What the fuck?
Okay.
I'm changing the date.
I have the date.
Alright.
I'm going back to time traveling again.
I'm coming back a couple of days...
Okay, let's see.
Just an hour...
Two hours later.
Okay.
And then...
They will talk to me.
They will talk to me, guys.
They absolutely will talk to me.
Guys, what's the button to make this full screen again?
I don't remember.
Okay, it's very tiny, guys.
Because...
I need to see if they'll talk to me first.
Okay.
Talk to me.
Children.
Okay, they will talk to me now.
I read the guide again.
I figured it out.
The children shall talk to me.
Oh, I don't know what he said.
Oh, I don't know.
I just pressed start.
I don't care anymore.
Okay.
I'll give you guys a little bit of heat.
I don't know if you are starving or not.
Okay.
I think...
Hello!
Fish!
Hello, you fucking shithead!
Talk to me!
Why won't you talk to me?
I don't understand.
What do I have to do?
Please!
I just want you to talk to me!
Is that so much to ask for?
Okay.
Does anyone want to talk?
Hello?
Why are they all ignoring me?
Wait.
They are all ignoring me.
Except for you.
Hello!
Fish!
Fish?
Speak!
Fishy fish!
Okay.
It's okay.
Everything is fine.
It's the A button, right?
It's the A button, right guys?
To talk to my fishies?
I'm looking at the manual.
I just want them to talk to me.
I don't understand.
Why won't you talk to me?
I did so much.
I cared for them.
It's the A button.
It is the A button.
Was it?
My god.
It had to be, right?
There is...
Hello?
Fish.
Fish fish fish.
Talk to me.
You have to talk to me.
Talk to me or I'll kill you to death.
Fish.
Eat!
Please!
Eat your sisters!
Eat your brothers and sisters!
Please!
Eat!
Just eat them!
Why won't they eat?
I just...
I just need them to eat.
That's it.
Okay.
I got this.
I tapped the glass twice.
Eat!
Fish!
Speak!
Hello?
Hi!
I took care of them for so long.
But they're still kids.
They're still kids!
Why are they still kids?
Why can't they just eat each other?
Eat each other!
Eat!
Hello?
I can't...
I can't kill these fucking fish.
I just want them...
I just want them to evolve.
Why can't you evolve?
That's all I want!
I just want them to evolve.
I don't understand.
Why you don't...
Why you don't evolve?
Eat!
Hello?
Fish!
Oh my god.
It doesn't...
They don't evolve.
They said they evolve...
in three days.
It's been longer than three days.
How are they still here?
How are you still here?
You're supposed to be evolved now.
I don't understand.
Why are you here?
A week?
I was told three days.
And you're telling me there's still gonna be little fishies?
After three days?
I can't believe I was lied to.
You all said three days and I believed you.
It's actually...
Oh my god!
Goodbye, fishies.
Goodbye.
And they take a few weeks to evolve?
Fish.
Hello.
Fuck you.
Fish!
I hate them.
I hate my children.
I hate them so much.
Oh my god.
Why won't you do any...
Why?
Okay, I'm gonna...
wait.
Select microphone.
Okay, I...
Okay.
It's fine.
I'm looking... I'm reading something real quick.
I'm reading something.
That might fix it.
I'm reading something real quick.
It's okay.
I can do this.
I can.
It's okay.
I can do this.
I will make my fish listen to me.
I love my fish.
My fish is gonna listen to me.
One of them is gonna listen to me.
Hello!
Fish!
I'm killing them.
I've had enough.
I'm at my breaking point.
I'm done.
Don't keep releasing them.
I'm fucking done.
I can't.
I can't keep doing it.
I...
Guys, I can't.
I'm not strong enough.
I'm not.
Okay, I'll do one more.
I'll...
I'll do one more thing before I kill them.
This is the last thing I'll do before these fishes die.
This is the...
This is the last thing I'll do before I kill them.
I'm just not strong enough.
Guys, I'm not.
I can't.
Guys, I'm not strong enough.
Okay.
This is my final attempt.
Just one more day.
I don't have no more one more day.
Guys.
I don't think you understand.
I don't have another day to give anymore.
I don't think I have another day to give.
I'm not strong enough.
Okay.
Four.
Nine.
Six.
Alright, that's a fine time.
Okay.
Alright.
Yes, I tried to read the mic.
And the mic is just not working.
I thought I got the mic to work, but it's not picking up my mic.
Okay.
I'll give him one more day.
I'll give them one more day.
But if those fishes do not evolve...
We're saying goodbye to these fishes.
There's still eight men.
That's nice to know.
That they're having a great day.
Wow.
I'm so happy for them.
That they're enjoying their time in this habitat.
Alright.
One last time.
One last ride.
I should give them one more day after that.
Get over here, little sea man.
Get over here.
I need to talk to you.
Come on.
Come on, swim over.
Fish.
Hello.
It's over.
Say goodbye to all of them.
Say goodbye.
It's over.
Hello.
Hi.
It's over for them.
They don't know it yet.
But I do.
I know it.
I know it's over.
I know it's gone.
We did it.
Okay,
I didn't...
Okay.
I know it's over for these fishes.
It's over for all of them.
They've done their best.
Hello.
It's over.
I'll give them one more day.
And then it's off to two years.
And then we're going to next year.
I gave them a chest.
The last day before their...
The final...
The last supper before they...
Before they die.
I'll even give them...
I'll even give them a little treat.
I'll even give them a little treat before they die.
A final supper, guys.
Dawn of the final day.
Because I feel so compassionate.
Oh no, I know how they talk.
They just refuse to talk to me.
Oh my god.
That's fine.
They're fine.
They're okay.
Look, see?
Look how okay they are.
Look at that.
Not even gonna try to put it at...
I'm not even gonna try to put it out at 19.
From mother to executioner.
That's enough air for... That's enough air for all of you.
You refuse to evolve.
So I... If you refuse to grow up and pay rent, it's goodbye for all of you.
Oh, you don't even wanna get near the glass?
Get near the glass right now, kids!
Get in here!
Oh my god, they don't even...
They don't even...
They don't even listen to me anymore.
They...
They don't even listen to me.
They're not even looking at me.
Why don't you look at me?
They don't even look at me anymore.
I'll pick you up.
Can I kill them if I pick them up?
Suffocate.
Can you die from lack of water?
Is that possible?
Is that actually possible?
Is it possible to just not be able to breathe?
They don't even look at me.
Look at...
Except for this guy, this was my favorite.
Hello!
Are you fucking... okay.
Okay, now you look at me.
Okay.
Okay, wait, wait.
Okay, there you go.
Okay.
Hello!
Fish!
I'm gonna kill them.
It's time.
The verdict has been delivered.
I have decided their fate.
I have decided...
I have...
I have decided their fate.
Oh no.
Oh no, how could this have happened?
Who would have thought?
Alright, where's the air?
I need to see this.
Where are their bodies?
Do I even get to see where their bodies...
Do I... do I even... do I get to see where they died?
Alright, thirty...
Thirty-four...
Forty-five...
Where were their bodies at?
Oh, it's just empty.
It's just... it's just empty.
It's like they were never there.
Hello?
Oh, there they are.
Fuck!
Oh my god, there they are!
Oh shit!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, there they are!
We can't pick them up?
Oh, they're doing...
Tickle, tickle!
Tickle!
Come on, laugh!
Or are you just pretending?
Oh my god!
They won't let me pick them up, I don't know why!
Hello!
Fish!
Oh yeah, I got an idea!
Food time!
Hey guys, there's food!
Hey guys!
Guys, come over here!
There's food!
Oh my god!
Guys, there's food!
Guys, speak English!
Guys!
Oh my god!
Oh shit!
The accident was five years ago!
The sea matter did it!
It was absolutely your fault!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you Liam!
They never ate each other!
It's all I wanted!
Oh, and they're floating down!
They're floating down!
Oh my god, why are they floating down?
Oh my god!
Why are they floating down?
Holy shit!
Oh my god!
It's okay!
Tickle, tickle!
Hello!
Please laugh!
Oh shit!
Oh my god!
His eyes opened!
Hello!
Holy fuck!
Stop!
It's really fucked up!
Okay!
They never got to talk!
How unfortunate!
They never learned how to talk!
Oh, very unfortunate!
I tried my best, guys!
And they never will!
Maybe one day, I'll get the microphone working again!
And then we'll have to talk with them again!
Another time!
But we tried our best!
We tried our best!
Maybe one day, they'll talk to us!
Tarkus, thank you for the superchat!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you, everybody!
They look so happy!
They look so happy now, like sleeping!
They're sleeping!
Everyone, they're just sleeping!
I hope you guys still enjoyed the stream!
Even though it was pretty scuffed, because I could never get them to talk to me!
Because I just picked the microphone!
It just never worked in the end!
But I hope you guys still had a great time watching!
Thank you!
What a journey today we had!
What a fun journey we had with our little semen right here!
Our little Gilmen!
Crossfire, thank you for the superchat!
Thank you, thank you!
Tarkus, thank you for the superchat!
Medi, thank you for the superchat!
Thank you, thank you!
They're descending to hell!
Thank you for the superchat!
Thank you, thank you!
Hey guys!
MrBrokenPawn, thank you for the superchat!
Thank you, thank you!
Let's just all forget what happened here today!
Guys, I have an idea!
Wait, wait, guys!
It never happened!
As always, I'm going to head off now.
I might do a Rivals ring stream tonight, I don't know how I feel.
I'll see how my voice feels later.
But, delete the evidence.
It never happened, guys.
They never existed!
The Killman never existed!
Anyway guys, as always everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you, except for me, head to bed.
Cause, you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody!
Bye guys!
Bye!